musk is known for being outspoken on
social media but he was silent when
questioned by journalists while leaving
his Beijing Hotel
the Tesla chief executive is visiting
China for the first time in three years
and the government has ruled out the red
carpet for him
China has always welcomed business
people from various countries including
Mr musk to visit China to better
understand the country and promote
mutually beneficial cooperation he's
visited the Commerce and information
technology Ministries and also met
foreign minister qingang the foreign
Ministry released a statement saying
musk had complemented the Chinese people
for being diligent it also stated musk
said the economies of the U.S and China
were intertwined China is Tesla's second
biggest Market its Shanghai Factory
produced 700 000 Vehicles last year
nearly half of the company's Global
output but the brand faces increasing
competition from Chinese car makers Elon
musk's visit comes at a time when
tensions are high between Beijing and
Washington the Biden Administration is
leading a push to decouple from Chinese
technology firms making it increasingly
difficult for multinational businesses
to operate in both markets
but while some U.S manufacturers are
moving production outside of China Tesla
is seeking to expand here with plans for
a second plant
despite all of this suspicion these are
the economic and technological
connections with China is booming it is
more valuable than it's ever been and I
think if you are a policy maker or
political leader in Western Europe and
even if you're a business in the United
States you recognize that China remains
an indispensable Market Elon musk's
usually active Twitter page has no
mention so far of his visit to China
Chinese internet users haven't been so
quiet and lavished praise on the
entrepreneur calling him pragmatic and a
Pioneer Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing